oh hello there I didn't see you
good evening welcome to the Sam and Nico
channel where I am neither Sam or Nico
my name is Ren and I'm very happy you
could join us this evening we have a
very special program indeed we have the
holiday special from corridor digital
darts Santa I hope you enjoy and let us
begin JJ Abrams and I we go way back he
even decided to name the newest if lords
after me the Knights of Ren we could use
a green screen but with the black
ditches on the side of it I tend to just
to do the rush yeah you're come right
now so useless oh we want to hear 12
other jobs don't come never come back so
the idea for this video came about from
the two word sentence darts Santa and
from there were like yes yes everyone
and their mother is doing a Star Wars
video we have to get on board - you
can't just wanted to simply not just put
on a Darth Vader costume so it was funny
wearing the Darth Vader costume because
it has an interior pleather full-body
jumpsuit that goes underneath everything
very similar to oh I don't know the
master chief costume problem with these
I don't know who's making these out
there but whoever does lives in
Antarctica because you put these things
on and it's like your body temperature
immediately just heats up the
stormtroopers were a little behind again
and I had to ask him to come in on
Saturday after you hey um how Michael
this is like my friend
so apparently this is on Amazon and
basically just a bunch of 80 eighties
pulling along a Santa's sleigh with
Darth Santa and it literally just Darth
Vader with a Santa hat going towards the
Death Star that's pretty much exactly
what we had in mind for the closing shot
of this whole video Wow
just goes to show no matter how original
you may think your idea is someone else
is probably already done it and put it
on a t-shirt and fortunately because
there isn't really a like narrative
throughout the piece it's mostly just
kind of a montage it didn't require a
lot of prep work that a traditional
video might have or it's like alright we
have this scene to do because it leads
into this scene because we're doing
everything montage style we can kind of
just shoot stuff as it goes and then in
the Edit just kind of throw it all
together like a big tumble soup of
spaghetti so what we tried to do is find
locations where we could do anything we
want like knock over Christmas trees and
do funny other practical things that
only dark Santa would do so friend of
Jake's has this house and loves
Christmas and it's pretty dang cool so
let's go take a look the place where we
eat dinner
the place where we
eat fire and those things really play
into the post production side of things
because we don't have a lot of time to
make a bunch of 3d elements or a bunch
of VFX to really make the video like
visually epic hopefully the signaling
line won't snap I know the anchor won't
snap because I engineered it to
perfection top job
if you're ever on a shoot and you're
kind of confused as to the order in
which to set things up this cause Sal
you're good old buddy s al and what that
means is s for subject who are you
filming a for angle where's your camera
gonna go L for lights where is the
lighting gonna go s IL everybody should
call him so we'll come down the stairs
we're in the corner and stop the bout
right here so me like Santa and so this
is going to be our angle here we're
gonna need to move the coffee table so
kind of like his head height made a
little higher kind of looking down this
is definitely a mainframe so we want to
make sure this is ours
Rebecca you have failed me for the last
time my peasants so Jake went down the
street to Walmart and for like 40 bucks
bought this little girl bike and the
girl bun so Jake bought this little pink
bike for boys and it boy oh my god this
pink bike with tassels on it it's like
legit tangled let me know get this off
I'd have to undo this already it's like
the middle little doggy doing a little
I'm like okay we got one take out
of that so then as Jake was running for
the down the street it got caught again
but this time instead of just getting
caught it ripped the entire cape off
damn it
what an amateur Vader getting his cape
ripped off who does that friend Seth
Hendricks brought out his custom-made
stormtrooper uniform it's really cool to
see something that's cinema quality
handmade and fit to a particular person
I'm here with Seth Hendricks he came out
with this sweet custom-made stormtrooper
uniform I wanted to say thanks to him do
you want to see him in other videos
check out Mike divas fallout 4
Battlefront video that they just did
how's mom
what else can I say about you said you'd
say a lot of things hopefully you won't
though okay so a little Ollie doraville
little kid we've worked with him before
on the mean police video from last year
so here's the interesting thing about
working with kids is that they're all
pure enthusiasm totally willing and able
to do you know certain lines great you
just have to be really specific with
what you want and how to actually say
what you want them to say pretty much
the complete opposite of what you're
supposed to do with traditional actors
you're never supposed to tell an actor
how to actually say their line that's
their job not yours and after that we're
gonna have you meet like really scary
face cuz this is not Santa you don't
know who he is yeah so also because we
didn't have much time we had to keep all
the effects really really simple which
meant a little paint out sort of effects
things we could do really quickly we
also had a moment where darsana
like lightning bolts even though Darth
vader-like never actually uses lightning
that's always like the Emperor's thing
but you know whatever no one's gonna
care hopefully maybe some people will
care
so he'll actually has this huge pack
huge huge it was huge pack of plugins
that you can use in After Effects and we
use the Lightning effect from that
plug-in on this video yeah it's not paid
sponsorship at all for them but they
have this fantastic free software you
can actually edit composite and do a
bunch of stuff it's a it's a free
version of their pro software and it can
do pretty much anything you want so
remember those booster boards we had for
the mario skate video a few months ago
well I had him in my car when I got into
a seven car pileup on the freeway turns
out my boosted boards are not quite as
compressible as my trunk look I have
another one that's not broken but just
switch them out real quick we're not
actually done with the effect yet so
hopefully it actually looks fine Wow my
entire world is being turned upside down
the reason why Santa is red and white is
because of coca-cola
do we have to pay for saying Santa so I
know a lot of you guys have been asking
about music and this video even though
we haven't actually heard the music for
it yet I hope it'll be great I have a
lot of faith in Casey because he is an
amazing musician a great Orchestrator
really good at making a bunch of really
professional music he scored a lot of
our things like shot of Mordor you know
a smallest Empire and gun game pretty
much any time we're like we don't have
much time and we really need some great
music Casey comes along we're like yes
and that ends our tale for today I hope
you enjoyed it and I also hope you have
a wonderful holiday where we'll return
next year where we'll continue to make
fun of Carmichael and make sure he does
a really terrible job
ain't that right Carmichael yep yep see
you next year you may have noticed for
the last couple weeks Sam and Nico
haven't been in the videos on the same
makeup Channel well that's because
they're in Detroit shooting a feature
film which is one of the things we've
been telling you guys we're gonna do and
one of the things we've been working
towards for the last four years and it's
finally happening yeah they'll be back
in what two weeks three weeks after
Christmas
yeah after Christmas and then you won't
have to listen to me anymore so thank
God for that right